nous sommes en 1857 et ce tableau des
glaneuses de jean françois millet ces
scandales l'objet de la discorde une
classique histoire de lutte des classes
sur sa toile milliers met au premier
plan en pleine lumière
les personnes les plus misérables de la
société les glaneuses celle qui ramasse
dans les champs ce qui reste une fois
que tout le monde est passé la
bourgeoisie est outré obligé de regarder
ce qu'elle ne veut pas voir obligées de
porter son regard sur un monde rural
magnifié par l'artiste peintre 151 ans
plus tard le célèbre street artist
banksy accroche dans le musée de bristol
une version revisitée du célèbre tableau
revisiter le moins qu'on puisse dire
j'aurais sur l'original est toujours au
musée d'orsay
donc si nous rappelle ici deux
fondamentaux l'histoire de l'art le
premier aucun nouveau mouvement ne pars
de rien donc sir site le pouvoir de
subversion millet et en rajoute une
couche ça glaneuse assise au bord du
cadre
clope à la main prend la scène presque
cool et pourtant glané n'est pas glander
deuxièmement innover c'est sortir du
cadre
ici c'est une photo vaut mille mots ici
c'est premier degré explicite brut
visuel bien que n'étant ni fondateur ni
précurseur de ce mouvement artistique
donc si la star incontournable du street
art
il est aujourd'hui l'un des artistes
contemporains les plus connus de notre
temps street art art public art urbain
arts de rue arts populaires
le terme fait un peu débat peu importe
pour moi c'est d'abord une passion je
les observe comme une déferlante qui se
répand sur les villes du monde entier
comme
une vague artistique qui a pris la clé
des champs comme un art qui s'est
affranchi de son cadre pour rejoindre la
rue larressore dans la rue et se libère
de ses contraintes
plus besoin des galeries des curateurs
des musées pour exposer son travail au
public finit experts critiquent
l'historien d'art pour définir la
qualité intrinsèque d'une oeuvre son
identité et par conséquent sa légitimité
le street art est un art libre qui
s'offre à tous gratuitement sans filtre
sans intermédiaire c'est un art hors
piste qui a pris là la reprend la rue et
nous raconte une nouvelle histoire
le street art n'est pas une reproduction
in situ de ce qui existe déjà sur les
toiles des musées ou des galeries il
n'est pas non plus un huitième ou
neuvième art l'art urbain réinvente des
pratiques et des arcs-en-ciel la poésie
par exemple comme avec le couple
français mais les tubes qui ont écrit
les mots mais lille fait danser sur les
nuls autre exemple avec la photographie
regardez comment j r utilise son art
pour transformer le maire comme sur ce
qu'est à paris où il met le corps des
femmes en scène même constat avec les
installations à l'image du duo
australien pride un sikh qui utilisent
le grillage un canevas et des gobelets
en plastique peint comme médium poésie
photo
six installations mais aussi peintures
sculptures collages tricot même le
tripot devient un art urbain lorsqu ils
recouvrent des éléments de la ville des
arbres des bancs des voitures et même
des bus vous l'avez compris la rue n'est
pas simplement un support pour l'artiste
la rue et le médium la matière première
de love la reprend la rue comme malik le
street art fait avec avec les éléments
architecturaux avec le mobilier urbain
avec les fractures et les imperfections
de la ville un shot un impact un petit
pochoirs et up one quoique ressuscite
bruce lee les artistes s'amusent parfois
de détails insignifiants comme ce petit
bout de nature improbable que sandrine
boulet qui nourrit l'imaginaire
débordant de sandrine boulet ce
détournement m'inspire une pensée d'un
apple france qui dit en art comme en
amour
l'instinct suffit le street art peut
être minimaliste presque cocasse
lorsqu ils exploitent la simplicité dans
déchets banals laissé à terre un art
singulier que l'artiste anglaise king
catch où travaille depuis plus de dix
ans mais le street art peut être
grandiose
lorsqu'il se met à l'échelle de la ville
à l'image de 7,1 à morphose cet immense
anamorphose peintes au caire dans un
quartier du caire par l'artiste franco
tunisien el cid difficile pour moi de
vous parler du caractère grandiose du
street art sans vous montrer le travail
de l'artiste allemand ecb 70 mètres de
haut et le tout peint avec des bombes
aérosols c'est monumental
prendre la ville comme allié c'est se
nourrir de milliers d'opportunités
d'innover artistiquement et de
réinventer la ville au risque parfois de
rentrer en conflit avec les pouvoirs qui
la gouvernent mouvements autorisés au
mouvement sauvage la reprend la rue de
gré ou de force
l'air de la ville rend libre liberté
d'expression liberté de création liberté
de paraître liberté d'occupation du
territoire
l'air de la ville rend libre au risque
parfois de rentrer en collision avec les
pouvoirs qui la gouvernent comme le
pouvoir économique par exemple et sa
capacité à acheter à saturer notre
espace visuel en toute légalité
je sais peindre librement dans la rue
est interdite partout dans le monde ou
presque
et pourtant les artistes sont imposés le
risque et la transgression sont dans
l'adn de sony d'un côté il ya les
artistes qui cherchent les emplacements
numéro un c'est-à-dire les murs les plus
exposés les plus visibles donc soumis à
autorisation comme ville ceux par
exemple ce génial street artiste qui
défonce les murs au burin à la pioche au
marteau au marteau piqueur et parfois
même à l'explosif ne peut pas intervenir
sans se faire voir et surtout sans se
faire entendre
donc avec autorisation ceci est un
détail du mur je vous laisse apprécier
l'oeuvre dans sa globalité
de l'autre côté
il ya les artistes qui revendique une
liberté totale et ne négocie pas avec
les autorités l'image de ce mur peint
librement sans commande par l'artiste
brésilien luiz even martin dans sa ville
de sao paulo
alors autorisations et interdictions et
qui dessine le droit créées dans
l'espace public et la question
fondamentale est structurelle du street
art les artistes ont choisi leur camp
ils ont pris la rue de gré ou de force
propulsé ces dix dernières années par un
spectaculaire amplificateur un autre
espace de liberté le web la reprend la
rue et les écrans une oeuvre réalisée
aujourd'hui peut être vu par des
millions personnes demain les photos de
street art à bong littéralement sur les
réseaux sociaux
ils font parfois le buzz à l'image de ce
mur qui réunit tous les ingrédients pour
rebondir de miran mur de tweets en
tweets d'instagram en instagram
c'est marrant cet art qui est sortie du
cadre revient dans celui de nos petits
écrans via nos smartphones devenus des
capteurs et des diffuseurs d'image
omniprésent c'est un mouvement étonnant
à observer la fréquentation massive à
distance via nos écrans génère en retour
une fréquentation des oeuvres dans la
brévine l'habitant le touriste l'amateur
d'art se déplace dans la rue pour aller
voir des oeuvres en vrai des oeuvres qui
s'agrège et se densifie donc des zones
urbaines favorable à la création
certains quartiers sont devenus de
véritables musées à ciel ouvert tant la
densité des oeuvres est importante
quelques exemples où il vaut d'amis
brooklyn
boucherie qu'à new york le liste end à
londres rosberg à berlin ou plus près de
chez nous le xiiie arrondissement à
paris ou vitry sur seine se visite comme
de vrais musée avec des guides et des
tours organisés par le monde associatif
et touristique grâce au web
cet arrêt fait mais éphémère est devenu
éternel et mondialement populaire avant
d'être officiellement reconnu la reprend
la rue et les dollars le street art est
devenu vraiment bankable il affiche
wendel des records comme cette toile de
banshee vendu au prix ahurissants de 1
million 700 mille dollars lors d'une
vente aux enchères au 2008 à new york
la boucle est bouclée
les artistes qui sont sortis du cadre
pour rejoindre la rue reviennent dont
celui beaucoup plus lucratif et
spéculatif du marché de l'art s'agit
hier comme un appel d'air des artistes
les plus renommés les plus connus les
plus célèbres les plus talentueux d'un
envie aux plus jeunes de prendre la roue
est probablement la relève et pourtant
même s'il est très présent l'argent
n'est pas le principal moteur de ce
mouvement car la reprend la rue et le
citoyen
cette pensée de victor hugo me parle
la rue et le cordon ombilical entre le
citoyen et la société la démocratie est
dans la rue la démocratie sa fiche là
nous sommes bien
en france pour le savoir qu'ils portent
ou non un message politique
le street art révèle de manière
pacifique
la centaine nos démocraties à l'humeur
de l'époque joie colère humour injustice
amour tristesse s'affiche sur les murs
sans autorisation avec parfois la
douleur d'un peuple tout entier
comme l'année dernière à paris et ce mur
de julien malland pain lendemain des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015
le street art nous connecte à la ville
et à la vie sociale il tisse un lien
entre nos et la société pour reprendre
la citation de victor hugo il devient un
bien et un langage commun
c'est un art facétieux qui joue avec les
effets de surprise c'est une invitation
à sortir à explorer la ville à être
attentifs à lever est né à quitter les
sentiers battus et les autoroutes
touristique être en contact avec le
street art ne nécessite ni connaissance
ni culture de l'art ni argent c'est un
art gratuit qui sauf qu'il y ait la
portée de chacun d'entre vous à la
portée de tous populaire l'a appris ma
rue je suis devenu passionné d'art
urbain sans jamais avoir reçu aucune
éducation à cette passion vient
assurément du lioger des plus anciens de
famille un milieu hyper humains paysage
de murs plus tôt dès que je me plais
aujourd'hui à imaginer oeuvre d'art
c'est tout
fanni s'est forgé mon goût pour la
transgression qui résonne à merveille
avec cet art hors piste aux origines un
peu punk
trente ans après la prime a
littéralement l'an dernier jour de mon
anniversaire
quelle surprise lorsque j'ai ouvert mes
volets de découvrir sous mes fenêtres
sur mon trottoir
cette jeune fille bombe aérosol à la
main en train de taguer la porte de mon
garage
mon ami jérôme artistes qui signe ses
oeuvres sous le pseudo de obs était venu
discrètement pain se pose choix juste
sous les fenêtres
une bonne occasion de rappeler combien
notre amitié étaient robustes les
haussiers combien notre aventure
créatrice commune était riche et
passionnante
jérôme et moi avons créé il ya plusieurs
années le site web street art à venir il
est devenu avec le temps un musée
virtuel qui garde une trace de mes
voyages mes explorations urbaines de mes
coups de coeur pour cet art éphémère
street art avenue offre même la
légitimité d'organiser en pleine rue
délire comme ici cavale l'année dernière
avec le très renommé artistes ron ce mur
peint juste en face du palais des arts
il y en aura peut-être d'autres
il veut être un chat vous qui sait et
vous
comment est ce que l'art va prendre
votre rue seriez vous prêt à laisser le
mur de votre maison
celui en face de chez vous un street
artiste pas simple les goûts et les
couleurs ne se discutent pas c'est vrai
et d'ailleurs ce qui vous ce que vous
aimez pourrait faire frémir de dégoût
votre voisin et réciproquement
et pourtant certains et peut-être même
certains d'entre vous loue un bout de
leur jardin ou le mur de leur maison à
des annonceurs s'affiche à 4 mètres par
3 imaginez une ville où les panneaux
publicitaires soit des toiles libres
offerte aux artistes
imaginez que nos entrées de ville ne
soit plus recouvert de messages
commerciaux les d'oeuvres d'art
cela manches à rien d'y penser je vous
invite à vous laisser surprendre par ses
oeuvres inattendue qui ré enchanter nos
villes je vous invite à ouvrir grand
votre regard sur cet art inattendue je
vous invite à devenir des patients en
pleine conscience de votre environnement
et à ce titre
j'imagine que vous avez déjà tous foulé
le port de vannes
est-ce que avez vous remarqué des traces
de peinture qu'il y avait sur la grille
d'aération du parking souterrain qu'il y
en a fait le tour qui s'est penché pour
finalement découvrir qu'il s'agissait d'
une anamorphose ce portrait pas en 2014
par hawks et celui du célèbre navigateur
irritable
alors avez vous changé votre regard sur
le street art
allez vous explorez la ville autrement
merci